Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow
of death, I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Good morning, church. Uh, my name's Tiara Lewis
and I'm one of the elders here at Henderson Hills.
It's a joy to get to be with you on this summer,
Sunday morning, uh, studying the Psalms.
So that's a lot of s's I'm practicing, uh,
and getting ready up here, um, in the pulpit.
So we're thankful that you're here today.
Um, last week we got to hear from Perry Walker, uh, teach
and walk with us through Psalm 65.
And today we'll be studying Psalms chapter 66.
So if you wanna turn in your word there.
Um, next week will be obviously in 67 and,
and hear about letting the nations be glad.
And both of, both of those chapters contain the phrase
to the ends of the earth, to the ends of the earth.
And then today we're going to talk about shouting
and singing and saying that the Lord is good.
So before we begin our time, let's go to the word in prayer.
Father God, um, we thank you
for your word this morning.
We come together as your body, as your bride to study it.
We pray, Lord, that your spirit would speak
to our hearts corporately, but also individually.
I pray, Lord, that um, the words that you've given to me,
that your spirit would communicate
and that your word would ring true.
Lord, we love you. It's in Christ and we pray. Amen. Amen.
So last week, Perry started off with a question.
His question was, how big is your God?
And my question this morning
that we're gonna talk about a little bit is
what gets you excited?
What gets you excited?
And I went to school at Texas a
and m, whoop, for any Aggies.
Uh, we're gonna talk about whooping.
So if there's any Aggies in the audience,
we're gonna learn about that today.
And Texas a and m is a place that knows how to get excited.
In fact, there are more traditions than we could talk
about in a Sunday morning.
And freshmen going into a
and m go to a whole week called Fish Camp,
where they learn all the yells
and the hand motions, the songs
and the stories of Texas a and m.
They learn about what it means to be an Aggie, even
before they stepped foot on campus for the first time.
And one of the most famous traditions is the Aggie whoop.
And it goes through different iterations depending on
what year you are in school,
but you may hear it at football games or basketball games,
or even in class.
Uh, anytime something's said, that's good.
You might hear whoop and has even infiltrated the church in
College Station so that
after baptisms when brothers
and sisters in Christ come out of the water,
the sanctuary rings out in whoops,
in jubilant shouts of joy.
And so as I opened Psalm 66 and looked at it,
and the psalmist says, shout for joy to God,
I was taken back to Central Baptist Church
where we were whooping right there in service.
And so the other, the other tradition they have is one of,
uh, midnight Yell practice.
And at midnight Yell Practice,
they practice all these things at midnight,
they practice the yells, they sing the songs,
we sing the songs together, and then they tell stories.
And the stories stir the, stir the hearts
of the students leading up to Saturday morning
for the football game, for the big game, we get ready.
And so this morning I pray
that this psalm stirs our soul.
So let's read starting off in Psalm 66, chapter one,
the psalmist writes, shout for joy to God all the earth.
Sing the glory of his name. Give to him glorious praise.
Say to God, how awesome are your deeds?
So great is your power
that your enemies come cringing to you.
All the earth worships you and sings praises to you.
They sing praises to your name, Sayah.
Now this sayah we'll see, it's a, it's a pause.
It's a moment to catch your breath, right?
When, when you're that excited, you gotta catch your breath.
And so the psalmist is catching his breath
because he's excited, he's calling this into worship.
He's pumped about his God,
and he wants the world to know about it.
And it's easy to get excited about the things
that stir our soul, right?
It's easy to get excited about sports or the stock market
or cooking or even old trucks or travel.
So many things can stir our soul.
And we, and we dive deep, we dive deep into those things
that we get excited about.
And it should be the same with God.
The more we sit at his feet, the more we rely on him,
the more we go according to his will for our lives.
We should get fired up.
We should be excited, and we should live in awe
of all that he has done.
So in some ways, our shouts of joy, our songs
can be a, a reflection
or an evidence of the depth of our relationship with God.
Because I know when I'm walking closely with God,
I can get really excited about it.
And I want to go more. The songs of joy are in my heart.
The shouts of praise are on my lips.
But when I'm not, the cares of the world can begin
to choke those things out.
And I look for other things to find that excitement
and other things to find that joy.
But our relationship with God, our understanding
of who he is, it should cause us to shout,
to kick our heels up
and shout, to throw our hands up and shout.
Don't forget to say you will Jeff Berkholder.
So we shout, we make a joyful noise to the Lord.
That's what we, we read about
and we sang about in Psalms 95.
Peter in the first chapter of his first letter calls it
inexpressible joy, that joy is almost inexpressible for us.
And we know that that joy is a fruit of the spirit.
It doesn't come from something
that we can well up on our own.
It's the work of the Holy Spirit in our lives.
So we, we shout with joy. That's right.
So next, next in this passage,
the psalmist calls us to sing.
So as we sing, we lift a melody of praise to God,
a melody of pleasing praise.
So what is a melody of pleasing praise?
Now, when we were worshiping, they had
to turn my microphone down, right?
Right. And I can't play any of these instruments,
but we all have a song.
We all have a melody of praise that we can lift
as the spirit weaves together the different
parts of our lives.
It creates a song that's pleasing to God.
Um, I heard a radio story even yesterday about an orchestra
in Vienna, Austria that's made purely of vegetables.
It's a vegetable orchestra.
And every, every performance they have
to make their new instruments out of what they have,
what they've gotten at the market.
And they put together these beautiful songs
that are a conglomeration of what has been
provided for them that day.
And the same is true in our lives,
that we raise a hallelujah, we sing a hallelujah
with our lives by what the spirit does in us.
And, and this song is a song to God,
but it should also be one that's enjoyed by the people
around us, right?
Our song, the Song of our Lives is one
that should be pleasing.
And when we get a song stuck in our head,
it can affect us, right?
It changes the way we look at the world.
And this most beautiful music of the spirit artistically
and creatively working in our hearts is
what the psalmist is calling us to.
He's calling us to sing with our lives to the Lord.
And then ultimately in these, in these first verses,
he calls us, he says, say to the Lord, say to God,
how awesome are your deeds?
So we share what is awesome about God.
And there are so many awesome things.
But you see, it's one thing to shout.
It's one thing to shout to get somebody's attention.
It's another thing to sing a love song
to your girlfriend or to your boyfriend.
But it's a far different level to sit with the one
that you love and to speak very plainly about the things
that stir your affections for that person.
And that's what we are to do to God.
We are to proclaim the awesome deeds
that we have seen him do.
Not because he needs to hear it, but
because it does our soul good to say it, to speak it.
You see, God is honored in our lives when we
speak of his good deeds.
And we are also blessed when I'm driving
to work in the morning and I see the sunrise
and I say, wow, God, what a beautiful sunrise.
Right? It blesses my soul and it honors him who created it.
When I'm enjoying nature outside playing golf
or working in the garden, and I look around
and I say, wow, God, thank you for the variety
of your creation, for the variety
and the beauty of what you have made.
It honors him and it refocuses my heart on him as well.
When I'm at work and I get to say, I get to share
how beautifully he made a child's broken bones to be healed,
it honors him and it blesses my soul as well.
And so as the psalmist, as we see the mighty deeds of God,
it should call us to shout, to get excited.
It should create a song of praise in our lives.
And also it's a discipline for us to sit
and to say, to share, how awesome are your deeds?
And one thing about being excited is that we want
to share it, right?
We wanna share the things that we're excited about.
And we see that in this psalm.
We see that, um, the Psalmist shares
on a corporate level and on an individual level.
So there's two parts to the story,
and that's true in our lives as well.
It's true that there's a corporate story, the story
of the body of God weaving his narrative.
And then there's the individual story of our lives.
Think about, think about a great movie
and how there's this big grand story,
but then also there's that main character, right?
So I think about saving Private Ryan.
So saving Private Ryan is set in World War ii,
and it tells a bit of the story of World War ii,
but really it's the story of a band of soldiers
and then ultimately of one man,
it tells the story of Private Ryan.
And this psalm is similar, right?
It tells the story of
the nation of Israel,
and then it also tells the story of the psalmist.
So let's start with the corporate.
The corporate story starts in chapter five.
I'm gonna read verses five through 12.
He writes, come and see what God has done.
He is awesome in his deeds towards the children of man,
he turned the sea into dry land
and they pass through the river on foot there.
Did we rejoice in him who rules by his might forever,
whose eyes keep watch over the nations,
but not the rebellious exalt themselves.
He goes on, he says, bless our God
or peoples, let the sound of his praise be heard.
Who has kept our soul among the living
and has not let our feet slip for you.
Oh, God have tested us.
You have tried us as silver is tried.
You brought us into the net.
You laid a crushing burden on our backs.
You let men ride over our heads.
We went through fire
and through water, yet you have brought us into a
place of abundance.
Amen. So in these verses, we're invited to come
and see, to come
and remember to place our mind on the good things
that God has done for the nation of Israel
to place our minds on his awesome deeds.
And the first awesome deed
that we see the psalmist praise God for
is the rescue of his people.
We see the psalmist praise God for the rescue of his people.
He points to the Red Sea, which is perhaps one
of the most famous stories
and most clear demonstrations of God's sovereignty,
of his care, of his rescue from the people they were,
they were fleeing from the Egyptians, right?
And they came up to this sea
and they didn't have anywhere else to go, but God made a way
and they walked through on dry land.
When our family was living in Nicaragua, uh, we,
we got exposed to a song.
There's a singer named Danny Barrios.
And Danny sings a lot of really beautiful songs.
Um, one of our friends
that was there would often on his guitar play
and sing a song called Hymn NoDa Victoria and the Refrain.
So it was a song all about God's victory, the hymn
of victory, the God's victory in our lives.
And the refrain was de ultra canto,
which means from the other side, I sing
that he was singing this hymn of victory from the other side
of the sea, from the other side of rescue.
And we see that in this psalm as well.
In fact, many times in our own minds, we can go back
to those places of victory,
where we see the Lord's sovereignty
that maybe we didn't see at that time, that we go back to
where we see his victory in our lives.
And we remember how God has worked as a family.
We keep a, we keep picture books from vacations.
And so we can go back and remember the good times
that we've had as we've traveled as a church.
Um, just last month we celebrated 60 years.
We, we celebrated all the good works that God has done
through our fellowship over this time of the victories one.
And we, and we look at it from the other side
as we move into to verse nine here, the Psalmist writes,
he who has kept our soul among the living
and has not let our feet slip.
He's talking about death, that God didn't let them die.
And you see, he understands that the right penalty,
the deserved penalty for the idolatry
and sin of the nation of Israel would've been death.
It would've been for God to let their feet slip.
But in God's grace and by his mercy, they've been spared.
God redeemed them, he rescued them.
In this verse, we are reminded today that the wages
of sin is death.
But the saving work
of Jesus Christ keeps our feet from slipping.
Without God sending his son,
our feet would've surely slipped
and we'd be eternally separated.
But God and his perfect mercy sent his son Jesus
to rescue us, to rescue us from the
penalty of sin and death.
And it changes everything about our lives.
It changes our perspective on God.
It changes our perspective on life.
And the nation of Israel,
after they were rescued, their relationship
with God changed, their perspective with God changed.
And the same can be true of us as well.
After we are rescued from sin
and death, our relationship with God changes
and our perspective on God changes.
The next corporate deed that we see the psalmist praise God
for is his refining of his people.
God's refining of his people. He writes this in verse 10.
He says, for you, oh, God have tested us.
You have tried us as silver as tried.
You've brought us into the net.
You laid a crushing burden on our backs.
You let men ride over our heads.
And we went through fire and through water.
You see, he recognizes the trials that they've been through.
He calls 'em what they are. They're hard crushing weights.
But then he also recognizes that it's for their good,
that he's brought them through that it's a refining
and a testing the same way silver's tested.
So he starts with silver. Silver is refined
through a heating up process in a crucible we call it
that there's heat that's applied.
And so it separates the impurities from the pure silver.
And that same thing can happen in our lives as well, right?
Our lives can heat up.
Sometimes it's through busyness that we take on.
Sometimes it's through the pressure of the world
that can feel like a crushing weight on our backs.
But in the lives of a believer, that weight can be refining.
It causes us to clinging to what is most vital.
We don't have room for anything else.
Theros gets burned away And we're left with a pure faith.
The valuable parts are what gets left through a testing.
And that's true with us as believer, as well,
the psalmist rights of being caught in the net or the trap.
And for the nation of Israel,
this looked a lot like the trials that they faced
during the time of the judges when they tried
to go their own way or or rebel against God.
And there were times of, of trial
and times of oppression, times of trouble that we see later.
He calls it. There were times that they tried to run ahead
of God in their own plans, in their own ways.
And he speaks of men writing over their heads.
And we see in scripture the nation of Israel being captive
to many different empires, right?
To the Egyptians, to the Assyrians, to the Babylonians,
and ultimately to the Romans, that these people
of God felt an oppression, but it caused them to focus
or should have cleansing and refining their faith.
But the end, we see that God didn't leave them there, right?
He didn't leave them in that place. He brings them out.
The Psalm says He brings them out, he into abundance.
And so we see that we praise God for his provision.
Last week, Perry talked about in Psalm 65,
the different words of abundance.
And I underline those as we were going
through the different words of enriching and abundantly
and bounty and overflowing that God provides for his people.
You see, the psalmist here says that you have led us out
to a place of abundance that God provides,
and he provides abundantly.
Now, if you're like me and you've been to vbs
and you've been to church camp,
you can't hear the word abundantly without thinking about
what verse John 10 10, right?
The thief comes to steal and kill and destroy.
But I've come that they may have life
and have it abundantly, that Jesus has come to provide
that life for us.
He loves us, and he sent his son to die for us.
But you see, it can be hard sometimes.
It can be hard in the midst of the fire.
It can be hard in the midst of the water.
It can be hard under the crushing weight to see
how God might be working.
And so it's even more important for us
to look at his goodness in the things of the past, to see
how he has proven himself true
and faithful throughout scripture
and throughout the lives of brothers and sisters around us.
And we see this play out every year about this time of year
where high school seniors are graduating, right?
They're giving their final speeches
and they're talking about how those four years were really
hard, but yet they were really good in the end.
And I see this in my life.
I I, I work in a residency training program
that's a really hard five years for men
and women training the surgeons.
But when they get to the end
and they're giving their graduation speech, they acknowledge
that what they went through was hard,
but they're really glad that they did.
They're thankful for it.
And the same can be true of the trials
that we are facing today.
If we look back at God's awesome deeds
and praise him for his rescue, his refining
and his provision, then we can have hope for today.
And in the ending verses, the psalmist makes a shift.
So he shifts from looking at the corporate at the nation
of Israel, their corporate rescue,
and refining to looking at the individual.
So let's turn our attention to chapter to verse 13.
He writes, I will come into your house with burnt offerings.
I will perform my vows to you that which my lips uttered
and my mouth promised when I was in trouble.
I will to offer to you burnt offerings of fattened animals
with smoke in the sacrifice of rams.
And I'll make an offering of bulls and goats.
You see, in the midst of these corporate stories, there are,
like we said, always individual ones, individual lives
that are changed as part of this grand narrative.
So if we look at Texas a
and m, there's all these rich traditions.
But as I walk through, I had my own experience.
One of my favorite memories, my personal memories,
is proposing to Julie under the century tree.
So the century, right?
So the century tree whoop, right, is a,
is a, it is an old oak tree
that spans over a sidewalk, right?
And you don't walk under it
unless you're popping the question.
Um, and if you do, then that's a bad deal.
But, but, but in that day, on that rainy day in October, uh,
we sat under that tree and I asked her to be my wife.
And so we have a memory of that.
We have a painting of that tree that hangs in our home,
or at least it did before our last remodel.
And it, it's somewhere else now, but, but we remember it.
Maybe we'll dig it back out.
So we remember those sweet times, those individual stories,
and they allow us, those individual stories allow us
to resonate that, that
although we walk through these hard times, God is looking
and he's looking just at me.
But as we read these verses, let's not fall into the snare
or to the trap that this,
this psalm is somehow made a deal with God.
Let's not, let's not fall into that trap to think
that he somehow was able to manipulate God by saying,
I will perform all these vows,
but let us not stop short of also considering
that God may have allowed these trials to run up to
that point, to that point of refining in his life,
to the point of desperation, to bringing him to his knees,
where he had nothing else to rely on but to God
and to profess his faith and his trust in God.
So I believe that that's the praise of these verses,
that the psalmist was brought to a place of brokenness,
that the only thing he could look and trust to was God.
And so he put his hope in him and in him alone.
And that created a worship inside of him, a worship
of praise to where he was vowing
to bring these sacrifices to the altar.
And so he turns the praise to the personal story.
And we see personal pronouns all over these verses.
In verses uh, 15 through 20. He says these words.
He says, come and hear all you who fear God.
And I will tell you what he has done for my soul.
I cried to him with my mouth
and high praise was on my tongue.
If I had cherished iniquity in my heart,
the Lord would not have listened.
But truly God has listened.
He has attended to the voice of my prayer, blessed be God
because he has not rejected my prayer
or removed his steadfast love from me.
Now, there's a verse we need to clarify in here as well.
Verse 18. It says, if I had cherished iniquity in my heart,
the Lord would not have listened.
So what does that mean? Does that mean
that God doesn't listen to our prayers if we're sinners?
No, he absolutely listens to the prayers of sinners
because we are all sinners and he listens to our prayers.
But what he's saying is that we are
to give our whole heart to God.
There isn't any sin.
There isn't any iniquity that we can hold back from God.
He tells us that we can't cherish those things.
We, we can't cherish the things of the world.
We have to lay them all at the foot of the cross.
And so we turn our attention to, we see in these verses,
God showing his love for the psalmist.
So we praise God for loving me.
I would say praise God for loving me.
Not because I've deserved it, but
because of his love that he has poured out.
And this is how the Psalmist closes out this song in love
that he sings of the love for the nation of Israel.
But he also sings of his love for me.
And we see that love on display.
Moving up in the text, we see the Psalmist praise God
for welcoming his prayer.
God is on his throne, but it's a throne of grace.
And he welcomes the prayers of his children.
He longs for that relationship for us to share with him.
There's a welcome Matt at the foot of the cross.
He welcomes our prayers.
And finally, the psalmist praises God.
He says, praise God for attending to my soul.
And we too can say, praise you God,
for attending to my soul.
So not only does God love,
and not only does God welcome,
which you in some ways abstract things,
but the Psalmist points to God's attending to his soul
in the, in the Spanish service in H-H-B-C-S pen.
We've been studying the fruits of the Spirit.
And the last two weeks we've talked about kindness
and goodness and the,
and there's similarities between those two,
but also some distinctions.
And in English and in Spanish, those words have a lot
of overlap and even sometimes used
interchangeably in scripture.
But there's a difference. There's a distinction in kindness
where it's an outward expression of care for another person.
And that's what I think about when I read this word, attends
to my soul that someone who attends is present, right?
When God attends to our soul, he's present in our lives.
When someone attends
or attends to a plant, they care for it.
God cares for our lives.
And so we praise God for that, for the individual care
and attention that he gives to us.
So let me tell you what God has done in my life.
So there's a collective story of God in scripture
of the Holy Spirit, redeeming people,
calling them to repentance.
And that story is grand, right?
It spans nations and centuries.
But also God has spoken to my life.
My story is one of hearing from the Spirit very clearly
and very surely at a summer camp
in Sky Ranch, Texas.
And the Holy Spirit convicted me of my sin, told me
of my need for a savior,
and then opened my heart to the reality of the free gift
of God laid before me.
I knew that there was a need for a prayer of submission,
but in that time, I, I wasn't quite ready, right?
But God continued to sing to my soul with words of grace.
And then I remember at Williams Memorial United Methodist
Church in Texarkana, Texas, kneeling at the communion real
and offering that prayer of submission to God,
accepting the free gift of Christ is my Savior,
and then giving him control over my life.
And it's been the greatest 35 years of whooping ever since.
Amen? Amen. Now, there have been times of trials.
Yes, there have been times of testing
and refining times of walking through fire
and water, it seemed and crushing weights.
But as the psalmist would say, I would say to you today,
come and hear all who fear God.
And I will tell you what he has done for my soul.
I cried to him with my mouth
and high praise was on my tongue.
If I had cherished iniquity in my heart,
the Lord would not have listened.
But God truly has listened.
He has attended the voice of my prayer.
Blessed be God because he has not rejected my prayer
or removed his steadfast love, love from me.